come one step closer and I'll illuminate
you with a soft glow and I'll clean your
clock Oh blimey look you've all made an
excellent decision to see this movie
you're clearly shrewd so let me lay this
out for you on March 31st my movie
DreamWorks the boss baby will be coming
out we don't have any talking
candlesticks but if that's the deal
breaker will cram one in there somewhere
I think the kid might be onto me look
the kids are finally getting along
that's nice I'm on a mission puppies are
winning and babies are losing my job is
to find out why now see if there's
someplace around here with decent sushi
I kill for a spicy tuna roll right about
now I will help you just to get rid of
you deal how do we get past the card
[Music]
I don't we're not go find this thing
what's all the racket isn't he adorable
I've got one for you too
what bummer I can't do this without him
we do make a pretty good team no
literally I can't reach the door tops
I've never been so humiliated in my life
[Music]
put that cookie down cookies are for
closers good plans we babies are having
a crisis babies aren't getting as much
love as we used to behold our mortal
enemy puppies Oh No